bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj oggi
ragazzi siamo sul primo horror che
faccio con con questa bellissima
macchina da cucire e siccome non ti voi
mi hanno suggerito che con questo in
teoria negli ora non posso scappare
perché c'è non è che posso toglierlo
quindi ecco e quindi ragazzi re che
possiamo cominciare anche se so che
questa sarà un'esperienza che mi lascerà
il segno ha portato poi vado a cercare
chi è che mi ha consigliato di fare gli
horror quindi mettiamo in chiaro le cose
e del tuo western agazzi re che possiamo
partire a chiede che ci sia non vedo un
cazzo già non vedo nulla e siamo partiti
bellissima sta cosa che devo fare è
bello the talisman tanto non press space
to stop
la leggenda dice la leggenda dice che
tutti quelli che sono entrati a cercare
il talismano ogni tanto non sono mai
tornati
non mi hanno mai conosciuto resta la
vera che ha fatto di provare perché sono
troppo curioso obiettivo trova talismano
va bè ragazzi
portate pazienza ma è prima il primo
gioco che faccio che [ __ ] che sono le
lanterne
il primo gioco che faccio con loculo
quindi non so neanche allora io non ho
neanche fatto un test qui non sogna
cazzo sto giocare allora non so nemmeno
spiegarvi quanto cazzo è strano giocarlo
con loculo su un horror c'è non vedo una
se.ga mi sembra quella azioni chiaro da
quanto tempo che non ti vede che ci fai
qua ragazzi obesi e obi che si è mi sa
che stava aspettando l'autobus è
qualcosa mi dice che non è passato è
stato un piacere però è comunque vada
avanti o se dite io ancora non ho capito
cosa diavolo ci sono che cazzo
avete visto anche voi lo avete visto
anche voi avevo con lo smi dalle
allucinazioni non è possibile che i
ragazzi io non vedo una sega
ma niente proprio 0 davanti è buio pesto
se semini compare la cosa avanti lancio
il monitor giorno hai bisogno
dell'occhio della discordia per accedere
a questa parte io devo trovare l'occhio
alla mamma mi mangi sull'ascensore
grazie che bella cos'è questa se ve lo
state chiedendo si sono un demente che
belli giocherò al porno con lo script
ragazzi sono cose che ti riempiono il
cuore in tutti i modi possibili e quello
mi ha riempito il cuore di 120 a
bastardo non farmi mi è cascato il
cestino che non vedo ovviamente ragazzi
visto da che parte da dove era quel
tizio giorno io sono fa vj vengo in pace
non no non fatemi e l'occhio ho già
trovato l'occhio mi cade l'occhio la
discordia perfetto madonna quanto sei
bello e io lo prendo è perché solo
tornare indietro davvero prima avrà mi
sembra troppo semplice se non vedo cosa
succede però non voglio sapere cosa
fatemi tornare al punto di prima poi
discutiamo su cosa devo fare misto
occhio perché ancora non ho capito cos'è
sto schifo così che madonna è più bello
dell'occhio di sauron ragazze che segue
occhio non vede cuore non duole
l'avete capita a noi a pezzi non lo so
ragazzi mi bastonate dopo devo capire
ancora dove sto andando perché talismano
ancora zio bobby odio
salve senta lei lei ea suo agio sul muro
vero perché vedo che si sta divertendo e
mi fa un po strano
che cosa è successo i vari messo male il
piede cosa è successo la gara è molto
zio povere non è che prima fosse tanto
vivo è però voi non fate cazzate state
bene sui muri bravi grazie molto gentili
anche tu non ha una lucina del cazzo
anche non so una roba di divertente che
salva il teschio di solomon fantastico
non lo posso prendere però è troppo
lontano me ne torno indietro ragazzi ne
faccia un po a meno letters fiori
solomon anche se mi piaceva come cosa
che uno si piglia un braccialetto una
collana oppure il teschio di solomon
io so cos'è tutti io io sto continuando
ad andare avanti a non capire che cosa
stava yo yo tira la leva ok ok perfetto
ha vinto tutto la leva che ho tirato
qualcosa sarà servita perché non è
possibile
buongiorno è una bella giornata
cazzo no no no no no che è successo gara
guy sparito nome che mi rischio stato
nel muro come un idiota fantastico mi è
andata da dio che è sparito e finito
malissimo
vabbè prendo il teschio allora io non ho
ancora capito cosa mi serve sta roba
però torno indietro
devo ammetterlo da qualche parte suo
teschio credo che non è che l'ho preso a
caso ecco infatti posso posso metterlo
quant'è bello sto test ascensore piano
terra grazie molto gentile prossimo
molto braille grazie mille fantastico
hai bisogno di due chiavi per accedere a
quest arma che chiavi le chiavi che qua
io conosco il bodyguard sentiti o fammi
passare che ci conosciamo noi due ha mai
messo su un po di chili zio rendiamo ste
chiavi prima che zia bobbio s'incazzi
che è meglio però non so dove trovarle
credo più una sia di qua per volta
gli appelli si scherzi che mi fanno sono
fantastici
because i'm happy la palla e più per
vedo cose cosa hai bisogno della chiave
della luce per tornare in questa arma
[ __ ] che succede sento un urla tra
l'altro c'è mi hanno chiuso la porta
alle spalle si bastardi fantastico
devo capire però perché c'è della nebbia
io vedo nebbia salve garda ad un cazzo
regalo per una sega buongiorno bell'uomo
io non ho capito dove ecco la trovata la
chiave la luce premi la zio bobby di
merlo so che sei tu dietro tutto questo
bastardo morire anche tu ti occupi di
morire atrocemente vado ricavato dicono
vedo che il bello che non vedo una serie
a [ __ ] [ __ ] se gran grazie per
avermi consegnato agli horror con la
crus rift fantastico che poi questo è
anche un prototipo quindi la [ __ ] se
mi ricordassi le cose che vedo che sta
andando adesso di bene cos'è cazzo hai
trattato non passi su campo testa di
lampada certo che potresti farlo un
salto da zara e perché un paio di
vestiti addosso ti starebbero bene
insomma fare due passi in croce ma vi
sembra normale
ok la chiave della luce l'ho presa sarà
la prossima volta che vengo qua
giochiamo al rugby facciamo sia pochi no
non sia bobby è una trappola di merlo
sapevo che è lui che ha chiamato gli
amichetti per la briscola e non è che
sono tikwa caso a perfect man mezz'ora
per arrivare qua adesso c'è questa
bellissima chiave zio dove che te la
infili di preciso ma perché volevo
capirla sta cosa ma forse è meglio non
saperlo
calmati che adesso tocca al testo
continua ad andare avanti senza ancora
capire dove sto andando
e la cosa mi diverte e diverte un casino
16 spuntato testa di lampada per andare
avanti così tutto il giorno per quanto
mi riguarda è l'orario riposino zio devo
prendere questo ok ci sia ma a me la
chiave vieni qui l'eni che erano io vado
là dei perfette le piace stare comoda
questa chiave fantastico finalmente
mezz'ora chiave dell'oscurità non è che
mimì mischia così simpatica
ecco infatti non vedo più un cazzo no no
no no no che cazzo dove sono spuntati
istituti non fatemi capire che solo
caudina soffitto cosa non è così lurido
bobby sei stato tu dametti lo prega è
colpa di zio cioè tutta colpa sarà
l'altro osta chiave ma non ancora no no
non ci siamo capiti malissimo fatemi
uscire ma che mi sto calando leggermente
sottometti cani ma proprio di prove di
prepotenza questa vai
apriti sesamo due torce queste sono mio
premio grazie al viso nome quasi
ammazzato per due torce e rotante suo
talismano che me ne vado a casa grazie a
dio mezz'ora per arrivare a sto schifo
che poi secondo me in gioielleria costa
meno però nessuno si può a zio boemi
sembrava saranno sentite siamo nella
camera dei segreti probabilmente però
non vedo una mazza cos'è e bagnato terra
si sia proprio la camera dei segreti
regali lama e madonna poi abbiamo
lingotti volete favorire lega tanto sei
fra tutti è una roba anche per non
perderne o svoltosi stronzo vabbè io
prendo il talismano lo prendo el uniti
nelle ossa che tanto lo so che mi fate
qualcosa talismano 80 non ci siamo
ragazzi via l'ho preso l'ho preso ok
la lega c'è stata un successo
rega picchio beh va beh ma sei figo
allora è finito così cosa dalle barche
sparito quel giorno il tuo personale è
sì certo sali magari anche sulle nuvole
così leggo bene caso ragazzi è stato i
miei capelli ne hanno risentito
abbastanza questo caso erano non un po
così ragazzi ovviamente tra po usciranno
anche di paul nuovo dlc di outlast con
colloquio street quindi saranno cose
pazzesche in confronto a questo diciamo
che mi ha fatto cagare abbastanza sotto
perché c'è quando c'è il oculus sono è
leggermente diverso che giocarlo con
normalmente un videogame quindi mi ha
fatto effetto che che speravano mi
facesse comunque ragazzi lasciam perdere
e stato molto bello molto meglio di
mirabilandia giusto un pochino proprio
tutti ragazzi se il video è piaciuto
come al solito lasciato commento mi
piace anche a valiani facebook e come
non evita trovate nella descrizione se
lo zero per i siti iscritti lì ci
rivediamo nel prossimo video belle
ragazze